hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to troll face quest 13 now
you haven't missed any in between the
last one I think the last one was either
the Olympics or five but this is the new
one and as per usual it's sure to be
filled with stupidity and more honest
ism in oh hi oh come hey about the
witnesses poor guy being murdered oh
never mind then carrying on bubble wrap
Oh supposed to do that how was I
supposed to resist its bubble wrap oh
all the five-year-old's inside of us are
really rebelling this nevermind this
shut up I'm bad hello you earth you are
the most disgusting looking ostrich I've
ever seen in my life okay what's my
objective I guess I shouldn't be
surprised anymore about this game
because obviously I know exactly what my
objective is and it's total [ __ ]
practical your foot's is your weird
finger feet no matter what I'm supposed
to do I'm just supposed to hurt the
person Cray seems like this could be a
euphemism for something oink
again I did it with my big brain and my
big thoughts and my big ability to think
big and bigness big other things big
neverhood try it do it okay oh haha oh
look at you what a loser he is trying to
steal stuff oh this is the bank again hi
where the hell are you why am I here oh
I'm sorry does my music disturb you
does my everything else disturb you cuz
you disturbed me everything about you
disturbs me come on come on fall and
murder this person because that's the
objective right okay what else we got I
know it's keeping track of my clicks but
frankly I don't care at this point
oh boy is where things get lost and I
have no idea what I'm supposed to be
doing ray-ray
oh he was supposed to die anyway but why
did that happen that's not trolling
that's murder just fish booty
boo-boo-boo-boo-boo oh so sad for you oh
okay yeah I thought we were supposed to
make this guy said okay so good okay so
if there's got to be you've got to be
something he's gotta be the hood no
maybe I can
pick some of these you keep 100 there
hey buddy I'm not done my boy Wow
everyone's dead excuse me again this
game just leads to horrible horrible
murder and I don't know why okay
hmm where should I dump my nuclear waste
maybe in the sewer
so the Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles can
become mutant and teenage and turtles in
time hi hi hi you think you would stop
being surprised by oh well that was
environmentally sound and good for
everyone
hi what the hell is going on here you
somehow knew who's gonna come do I get
it leapfrog oh okay oh I don't know what
you're trying to do this is a fun game
between two loving people
okay fishing fishing fishing in the sea
fishing fishing you are me fishing
fishing let's go hi better down where
it's wetter is it better down where it's
wetter Oh God
thank you good boy why is that funny to
you are you saying you oh what's this
hello okay
doesn't make any sense
oh we did horrible things to these
people why are we worse Oh
Finding Nemo ended horribly okay
maybe I need to feed him until they get
big and strong and then they won't bond
to be eaten by anybody keep eating
give me the fake no okay I might be a
little lost here I don't know what I'm
supposed to do there seems to not be a
way to get there not dead I'm not
entirely sure what I'm supposed to do
ah puppy oh okay okay cool oh gosh well
I guess that's payback for all the
murder but oh well hello hi are you
trying to sleep I'm so sorry about that
I have to interrupt you wait does that
just mean
oh I make him cry that's all I did I
made him cry
Oh
oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh
he's dead oh you think you would have
noticed that his doom was approaching oh
well hi how's it going what do I need to
do 13 there is no 13 what do I do about
that
oh no oh okay failed that simply just
gave up on life write that in there 12
14 15 11 then no.1 3f l o 4 I don't know
I don't know man
yeah I think maybe Oh No okay I did the
thing oh man oh there's no outro
animation oh come on I worked so hard on
that that's it
okay well there you have troll face
quest 13 I don't know how many more
trophies quest it's gonna be but
apparently there's one on the App Store
so thank you everybody so much for
watching if you haven't checked out the
other troll face questions in a playlist
in the description below are the
indications are linked to you the videos
thank you again everybody for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video you know